the cassettes the DVDs and tape so we
can see the movies early and vote for
them fairly but someone in the Academy
was illegally selling their screening
copies on eBay Meryl Streep don't you
have enough
and now here's Jennifer Garner most
recently appearing in daredevil and
tonight she's sharing the stage with one
of the most beloved black actors in the
history of cinema Mickey Mouse
hello Mickey hello nice tux
ha nice shoes one two five toes will you
do the honors
whoo this is exciting the nominees for
best animated short film are no that's
my parking stub that's not it no here it
is
Darrin dugu couldn't do
Nick dog got it how do you say that Jack
the ring ha very funny Frodo
hmm runnin out of pockets
gosh it's okay Mickey you can use the
teleprompter huh oh thank you huh gee
let's see the nominees are
the Cathedral Tomic Baginski the chub
chubs Eric Armstrong Dothrak Kris Jenner
and hi Dave it linger Mike's new car pig
doctor and rogered cool mount kick
kochiyama Mura and the Oscar goes to
who the chub chubs Armstrong
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Erich Armstrong
I'm going to try real hard not to pass
out here on behalf of Jackie barn Brooke
our producer and the entire chub chubs
crew I'd like to thank ya your Landau
and Tim Sarnoff because without them
just this one wouldn't have happened I'd
like to thank everybody at Sony Pictures
Sony Pictures animation especially Sony
Pictures Imageworks if anyone's ever
done this kind of stuff before you know
it's about the team it's not about the
individual and I had the best team out
there and last I'd like to thank my
beautiful wife Penny thanks for putting
up with the long hours thank you
in the 19th century the prolific British
statesman Disraeli said that when he
wanted to read a book he wrote one today
he might say the same about movies so
many of us are making them that is the
case with short films not small films
but short films and of all the shorts
made every year these are the five
nominated this year by the Academy as
the Best live action short films trade
of a Dirk belly an and Anja dilemmas
I'll wait for the next one
Phillipe or Andy and Thomas go da índia
dog Steven paws Volsky and Jo whether
stone Johnny Flint Lexi Alexander and
Alexander Varner
this charming man Martin strung Hudson
and me on Jason and the Oscar goes to
this charming man Martin Starr hunson
and me and Jason
this is the first Academy
Penn's nomination from
and me Andre offend
Steve Martin one advice
lay off the onions well this is the
great honor
we brought the scriptwriter because
without a great script you cannot make
great film so well first of all we want
to thank the short fiction film of
Denmark it's a group it's a great idea
too bad it shut down and M&M productions
of Denmark thanks for supporting thank
you for choosing crew and cast great
talent I love you and everybody at home
of friends or loved ones we couldn't
make it without you thank you thank you